as we discussed 500 for the hardware and
the five-man crew the other one mill
will be delivered upon
the case so who are they Griffin is the
best hacker I've ever seen Marshall and
Baxter were the toughest guys on the
circuit Frank's the best lock man
outside of New York he's never taken a
pinch like his brother they'll be
hitting the bank right about now ladies
and gentlemen on the ground 30 seconds
we're home free brother oh did the cops
get here so fast
no sense in worrying about that now
whoever gets the package gets paid
Joey every minute I woke up next to a
dumpster where we parked a secondary
getaway vehicle but those 10 minutes God
gets him closer where's the package
probably whoever hit us has it to the
truth what the hell happened back there
I'm gonna rat in the crew what happened
they're in the vault huh
you tell me exactly what you saw I held
up my end Michael Chiklis someone's
playing me
Bruce Willis none of this connects back
to me I'm on it
who else was after this thing every
law-enforcement agency in the country
I really didn't know what your sting
must be pretty big for all this heat
so much for honor among thieves buying
ten minutes gone
you
you